it might be the end of October but the
big games just keep coming out don't let
battlefield and call duty stop you from
playing the mech piloting parkouring
first-person shooter that is titanfall 2
and this one has something the first one
didn't a full campaign you get lots of
abilities including the notorious double
jump while running and ziplining but
you're also getting an invisibility
cloak and a grappling hook to kill your
enemies with efficiency and accuracy
don't forget you can also call on your
Titan to rain down hell on everyone
there's different Titans too there's the
aptly named scorch who has incendiary
weapons and Ronin who focuses on
close-range combat with a sword I always
wanted to control a mech with a giant
sword wield your titan on the
twenty-eighth xenoverse fans are going
back to an extended version of toki toki
city to countenance it e in dragon ball
xenoverse to con tom city is seven times
larger to be exact just like the last
game you can customize your character
starting with race you could pick humans
sans megan's namekians and the freezer
race xenoverse to takes place two years
after the events of the first game and
someone is still messing with time and
you got to make it right some skills
will have to be learned through masters
like the previous game however some
masters will be found exclusively in
extra hubs like fries a ship the Elder
Scrolls 5 skyrim special edition is a
remastered version of the game releasing
for pc xbox one and ps4 it comes out
with all 3 DLC expansions and a complete
graphical upgrade for both consoles with
full mod support on pc ps4 and xbox one
you're still trying to defeat all to win
the world eater a dragon who's
prophesized to destroy the world the
game is set 200 years after the events
of oblivion and like oblivion you can go
anywhere and do whatever you want you
can complete story quests or you could
just go off on your own tangent and
forget the story all together
it's up to you and you get to start
slaying dragons on the twenty-eighth I'm
going to quickly breeze through a couple
chapter based games I don't want you to
forget first up there's Batman the
tell-tale series episode 3 new world
order it takes us back to Gotham to make
some tough times decisions as both Bruce
Wayne and the bat the Wayne name is in
serious jeopardy so it's up to you to
make the decisions that will change the
course of Arkham forever be the bat on
the twenty-fifth also I don't want to
forget about episode 5 of King's Quest
this is the final chapter of the
acclaimed series if you don't consider
the epilogue I really can't show very
much because it's getting spoilery but
this is out on the twenty-fifth finally
a new just dance is here for you to
sweat it out to a whole new list of
tracks you know you're gonna get your
usuals your Beyonce's and your Bieber's
but forget those jerks you're getting
Hatsune Miku the game comes out on ps3
ps4 xbox 360 xbox one wii and wii u but
Ubisoft also announced that the game
will be for the first time released on
pc via steam and it's even coming out on
the upcoming nintendo switch so you
could wait for the hardware if you
wanted to then you can dance anywhere
anytime that's out on the twenty-fifth
and that's all I have for this week have
a good one you guys and happy gaming